ده البابا فرانسيس بابا الفاتيكان قاده
جنوب السودان الى نبذ العنف الذي تشهده
البلاد منذ سبع سنوات ومنحي شعبي جنوب
السودان حياه افضل كي ينعم هذا البلد
الفتي بسلام وفي كلمه خلال زياره تاريخيه
لهذا البلد اعتبر البابا ان الوقت قد حان
لاظهار الالتزام بالسلامه
وصل البابا الى جوبا قادمه من كينشاسا ضمن
جوله افريقيه شملت الكونغو الديمقراطيه
ويلتقي البابا خلال زيارته رئيسه جمهوريه
جنوب السودان سيلفاكير مليارديت ونوابه
وهيئات المجتمع المدني
ينضم الينا منجوبا مراسل الجزيره هيثم
اويتام هيثم اهميه هذه الزياره زياره
البابا
نعم جمال اهميه الزياره تاتي في ان البابا
كشخصيه دينيه لها قبول هنا في جنوب
السودان ولها احترام واسع من اطياف
الكنائس في جنوب السودان وايضا شعب جنوب
السودان هذه هي زياره عنوانها الابرز
وتحقيق السلام وحث القاده الجنوبيين على
احلال السلام هذا ما قاله البابا في كلمه
له قبل قليل هنا في الامانه العامه لحكومه
جنوب السودان خاطب قاده جنوب السودان
الحكومه وايضا عباس الذين حضروا هذا
اللقاء وقال بان الوقت قد حان لانهاء
الحروب والاقتتال وايضا انهاء التدمير
الذي تشهده دوله جنوب السودان والعمل على
تحقيق السلام لكي ينعم ابناء شعب جنوب
السودان بحياه افضل ايضا البابا ارسل
الرسائل لشعب جنوب السودان ولابناء شعب
جنوب السودان بنبذل قبليه والعنصريه وايضا
والعمل من اجل احلال المصالحه بين
المجتمعات وتقبل البعض لكي يحل السلام في
هذا البلد المنهك بالحروب الداخليه ايضا
الباب ارسل رسائل قاده المجتمع الدولي
بمثمنا دوره في الدعم المانحين لدوله جنوب
السودان خلال الفترات الماضيه وداعيهم الى
مواصله هذه الجهود البابا سيلتقي خلال
زيارته التي ستمتد لثلاثه ايام عدد من
القطاعات سيلتقي ايضا النازحين في
المعسكرات الداخليه وايضا سيلتقي منظمات
المجتمع المدني وايضا سيلتقي رجالات
الكنائس المختلفه في جنوب السودان وسيقيم
قداسا يوم الاحد المقبل في ضريح الراحل
جون جراند ليقدم ايضا كلمه للشعب جنوب
السودان في هذه الزياره التاريخيه هذه
الزياره شعب السوداني يتوقع ان شكرا تنعكس
على
القاده السياسيين في ان يبدو التزاما
بتحقيق هذا السلام المرتجع هيثم اويت
مراسل جزيره متحدث ا من جوبا شكرا لك